Nev Campbell may not be returning for
Scream 6 but another fan favorite has
offered to let a TV fall on him if it
means he gets to come back so let's just
get into it head to 25 years later every
year I open the door and there's
Ghostface and they see me and they go ah
can you even make a Scream movie without
Nev Campbell she's been the star of
everyone so far but it seems like the
fifth movie may have just been her last
filming that one executive producer
Kevin Williamson actually said that the
movie's purpose had been to connect the
legacy cast members with a new cast we
are a little bit bummed to see her go
feeling a bit
um well just unhappy with the things
that were coming to me but as the
directors of the sixth movie pointed out
it felt like there's an opportunity to
really dig into this new crop of
characters without her so at least have
an ending to the story but that doesn't
mean we won't be seeing any of the
original cast returning for scream 6.
Gail weathers is back but maybe not for
too much longer if you're following
Courtney Cox on Instagram then you may
have already seen the video that she
posted to say just finish filming scream
but watch out Courtney Ghostface is on
the security camera he breaks in and the
video ends on a gasp that seems to
suggest that Gail may not make it out
alive for a sixth time and it's never
what I want speaking of returning stars
did you know the producers literally
could not find Hayden Panettiere I just
needed a break the last time we saw her
playing Kirby was back in Scream 4 and
although Kevin Williamson wanted to
bring her back right away they were all
left saying where's Kirby Hayden stepped
out of the Limelight five years ago and
with no agent there really wasn't a way
for anyone to get a hold of her it was
only by speaking through her producers
on Nashville that Kevin was able to
bring her back to Woodsboro for Scream
Six I just want to keep that ball
rolling I have a whole new team of
people ah good old Woodsboro the
fictional small town has served as the
Beating Heart for every film before now
Woodsboro was shot out of California
unless you're talking about Scream 4
where it moved to Michigan Scream 6
plans on taking us away from Woodsboro
and into the big city in New York and
according to Melissa Barrera this
setting is so much more mortifying than
anything we've seen before as she put it
when someone screams in a city where
everyone's kinda doing their own thing
then no one will come to their help the
killer for Scream 6 has done their
research they've been keeping a shrine
with every previous ghost-based costume
labeled with their original owner's name
with so many sane looking costumes
standing side by side you'd be forgiven
if you didn't know that Wes Craven
originally wanted ghostface's robes to
be White costume designer Cynthia
Bergstrom hated it and instead suggested
a type of fabric that could be lit so
that it gleamed almost like the glint of
the light hitting a knife this is the
robe we've seen in every movie since are
you scared Jenna no ghost-faced costumes
aren't the only ones in the killer
Shrine though if you look closely you
may also recognize a few other outfits
from the first film you can see Stu's
red robe Steve Letterman's jacket and
even Tatum's iconic green turtleneck and
orange shirt as outdated as these Styles
should be by now the first scream still
holds up and that was on purpose the
only Direction Wes Craven gave to
Cynthia Bergstrom was that everything
felt Timeless saying Cynthia you never
know people may be watching this film 25
years from now while West may have
wanted the styles to look Timeless
Courtney Cox had another idea every time
that she came back for a new movie she'd
come with a new look that was just over
the top gross or ugly or too much our
first thought those short bangs from
Scream 3. oh well that was the worst
apparently her hairdresser just started
cutting leaving her thinking well I
don't have a choice now never responded
with not a good release the highest
voice you could go Gail's too much
outfit for Scream 6 will be a bright
blue pantsuit with a pair of green pumps
our fans would be shocked they'd be like
what happened the original cast have
their memories from the set but they
aren't the only ones who grew up with
Scream Melissa Barrera remembers being
too young to watch any of the movies but
seeing her classmates dressed as
Ghostface on Halloween when she was
finally old enough to watch the first
three as a preteen she found them
terrifying but said I think it also like
led me to become a huge horror fan
Jasmine Savoy Brown on the other hand
well well her parents had a bit of a
different approach I wasn't allowed to
watch as a kid wasn't allowed to watch
the old Harry Potter wasn't allowed to
watch the old scream among our younger
cast Jenna Ortega has probably had the
least amount of time to shine she was a
little disappointed by her character in
the fifth movie saying that I only ever
shot with Ghostface and I was only ever
screaming and crying on the floor when
she signed on for the sixth scream
however she was very happy to have the
opportunity to give her character a bit
more of a personality and work closer
with her co-stars that cast and crew
they're my family so now that we've gone
on about everyone who's returning let's
talk about the ones still missed a
deleted scene from Scream 3 would have
made Stu the ultimate villain commanding
his army of ghost faces from prison the
idea was dropped but Matthew Lillard
still hasn't given up hope saying that
he's prepared to set up a public stunt
in which a TV falls on his head to prove
once and for all that stews not gone
speaking of actors waiting for a return
Scream 6 will be the first one without
David Arquette his character Dewey
didn't make it out alive from the fifth
one and David had a hard time saying
goodbye seeing everyone else move on to
work on the 6-1 made him go oh okay and
although he knows that he'll be sitting
out this time he's also made it clear
that he's ready to come back whenever as
he pointed out there is a Coming Back To
Life Element Within These horror films
yeah and this is going to be uh an
interactive circus like you've never
seen okay but for how much everyone
wants back in these movies are not easy
to make Courtney Cox and Nev Campbell
did so many of their own stunts which
was fine in the beginning
I'll do any stunt no problem this time I
was like that hurt the stunts weren't
only harder for Courtney to do when she
got older but she also felt that she
might have pushed herself too hard in
the first Scream movies saying that she
was definitely paying for it later so
Courtney's most memorable stunt may just
be her chase scene in Scream too fleeing
from Ghostface through a sound booth the
scene made great use of close camera
angles and left you wondering if our
main couple was doomed only seconds
after Dewey and Gail finally got over
their differences in fact the scene may
be just so memorable that Jenna Ortega
has hinted at Scream 6 calling back to
it saying there's a lot of that um Chase
sequences including one between Gale and
Ghostface through the lab so if being
chased by Ghostface wasn't enough the
cast on Scream 5 had another way of
getting your heart pumping Mikey Madison
thought it might be funny to scare Dylan
Minnette by hiding behind a bunch of
bags then just jumping around when he
was least expecting it we're like
welcome Dylan was already dealing with
some trust issues on set apparently
every member of the cast had been given
a slightly different version of the
script so that nobody really knew who
the killer was that'd be weird and
speaking of feelings our main three got
pretty emotional returning for scream
five Nev Campbell cried knowing that
this was the first movie she'd be
filming without Wes but for David it was
more the fact that he was working with
his ex-wife Courtney he cried so much
filming one scene with her that Courtney
said the next day the crew didn't look
at him yikes but David took it in stride
saying I could tell some people aren't
comfortable with that level of emotion
you know there's still extreme love
there and friendship so this franchise
has seen its cast through marriages
demises and even the birth of their
children which behind the scenes detail
did you consider the most shocking just
make sure to let us know down below